hola qué tal
ser policía implica estar cargado de
sueños implica poder contener un
contexto pero también poder realizar
ideas yo soy juan carlos quiroga soy
oficial de la policía nacional de
colombia y vengo a contarles una
historia una historia de como la
educación puede transformar realidades
en diferentes contextos
quiero hacerles alusión a una pequeña
imagen que ustedes pueden observar
hace más o menos dos años me encontraba
en un lugar de trabajo en colombia un
lugar que como ustedes observan me
sentía solo y esa soledad me lleva a
replantear muchas cosas a generar es
crisis
ustedes y yo muchas veces en el paso de
los días tenemos que poder tener esa
capacidad de resiliencia y encontrar un
camino un norte y ese norte está dado
por dar un valor agregado a nuestro
servicio y especialmente por poder
generar transformación en nuestra
institución
qué sucedió después
comprendí que como profesional de
policía podía tener en mis manos
herramientas fundamentales para poder
transformar a la sociedad es así como
puedo decir que el poder de las ideas
transforma no solamente los contextos es
de espacio y tiempo sino también nuestra
manera de pensar y de ver al mundo
una vez puede llegar a la escuela de
posgrados de policía un centro de
formación con altos estándares en
formación académica y en capacitación me
encontré con un reto pero para poder
llegar a ese reto tenía que tener muchos
elementos que en ese momento me hacían
falta uno de ellos era comprender
nuestro contexto social comprender
nuestro contexto institucional y más
importante aún comprender cuáles eran
esas potencialidades que yo podía
desarrollar
es ahí donde encontré un espacio dentro
de nuestra policía y entendí de que no
se trata de grados se trata de trabajar
en equipo
en este trabajar en equipo nació una
situación importante y fundamental poder
que alguien crea en nuestras ideas y
como esas ideas pueden llegar a
transformar esas realidades que nos
hacen a nosotros personas y agentes de
cambio social
una idea que estaba naciendo desde las
aulas de clase cómo hacer innovación me
llevó a pensar cómo puedo impactar desde
el contexto educativo nuestro servicio
de policía nace a tres elementos
fundamentales para poder construir una
idea el primero de ellos es tener una
idea que logre generar valor agregado y
esa idea de valor agregado ya estaba es
sembrada dentro de nuestra institución a
través del mando institucional comprendí
que llegué en un momento oportuno en un
momento de cambio y transformación
social y de una realidad institucional
donde la educación con un papel
importante
pero me pregunto que vieron en mí para
poder asumir este reto sabiendo que
muchas veces no podía tener quizás el
grado pero si tenía las ganas la
motivación y parte del conocimiento para
apoyar en este proceso transformador
esa persona que construyó esa idea me
permitió a mí modelar un equipo de
trabajo y a ese equipo de trabajo además
de impartirles sueños impartirle también
ideas y lo más importante trabajo
dedicación y esfuerzo es lo que nos ha
llevado a generar el día de hoy algo que
nosotros conocemos como innovación
social
esa innovación social tiene una
característica fundamental y es que
tiene una p la p de policía donde está
identificado usted o usted que nos está
escuchando pero también dos meses donde
yo me siento identificado cuál es la
característica principal de este espacio
que esta innovación desde la educación
nos ha permitido a nosotros poder
aprender un método de innovación que se
está dando en las aulas de clase con los
lápices con las ideas a peder a poder
transformar con trabajo cada una de las
ideas que tenemos sin aportar a una
sociedad en especial construir ese
construir nos ha llevado a interactuar
con personas del común con ancianos con
niños con el ciudadano de apie y poder
conocer sus necesidades y trabajar desde
ellas para verdaderamente dar un
significado cuando nosotros decimos
inspirado en usted
la pregunta que quiero hacerle a usted
es que estaría dispuesto a hacer por los
demás sabiendo que ese concepto de demás
son personas que quizás nosotros nos
conocemos y que con nuestro trabajo
silencioso abnegado desde un aula de
clases y especialmente desde llegar a
conocer y trabajar por nuestras ideas
podemos construir con ellos y un
elemento fundamental de poder trabajar
en estas ideas ha sido el transformar
hemos transformado realidades hemos
transformado también una revolución
educativa institucional una revolución
donde sin importar el grado sin importar
el tiempo de experiencia ha hecho que
las ideas se construyan y se trabajen en
realidad con ello podemos decir de que
teniendo un laboratorio como la ciudad
de bogotá en donde policía comunidad
instituciones y personal de diferentes
entidades han trabajado en pro de
construir una transformación social
hemos logrado impactar más de 12
localidades pero más importante aunque
nuestras ideas han impactado a 6000
personas en menos de un año hemos
generado sueños hemos generado ideas
pero las ideas se transforman con
métodos
ese método es el que nos ha llevado a
construir un cambio generacional y un
cambio de cultura en nuestra educación
policial los invito a romper sueños los
invito a romper fronteras y barreras
esas barreras del tiempo de la edad
muchas veces la barrera del idioma pero
que nos acerca en algo común somos
policías y ese orgullo de ser policía
requiere también colocar a flote que lo
que nosotros hacemos se vea se
transforme es así donde con esta
metodología hemos podido llegar a
transmitir la más de 25 países de
cuerpos de policía donde cada uno de
ellos resaltan en nosotros en el poder
transformar esas realidades que las
ideas tienen valor insisto aún frente a
ese proceso lo que buscamos con gran
sencillez con ese trabajo anegado de
docentes de muchas veces directivos y
especialmente de personas que creen en
las ideas
importar el grado que podemos construir
un mejor país podemos construir una
realidad educativa que genere en
nosotros grandes habilidades habilidades
de transformación porque no importa las
instituciones su estructura lo
importante es lo que usted y yo podemos
aportar en ellas para transformar y
generar realidades los invito puedes
hacer soñadores para ser soñadores con
ideas que generen valor que generen
verdaderamente identidad para así hacer
que las personas se nos acerquen cada
día más y por qué no dejar un país mucho
más sólido un país donde la educación
donde el trabajo en equipo y sobre todo
el respeto y el trabajo por las ideas
nos logren inspirar a usted ya mí
bienvenidos a esta revolución a esta
revolución educativa a esta revolución
ideas para transformar instituciones yo
soy juan carlos quiroga y esta es mi
historia